what's up et is Corbin Bleu here and I
am thought to go surprise the ghast of
High School Musical the musical the
series
buckle up Wildcats it's about to get
real
[Music]
[Applause]
again everybody
long time no Z this is my second time
getting hang out with these guys last
time I saw you guys it was at d23 yeah
and since then there's been some awesome
news
you guys were renewed for a second
season
tell us about High School Musical the
musical this series what is it that sets
this apart from the original High School
Musical franchise the musical the series
is about a group of students which are
us and amazing teachers over there who
go to East High where the original high
school musical was took their drama
teacher Kate over here realizes that
they've never put on a production of
High School Musical where High School
Musical was shot that's crazy
yeah so they end up doing auditions and
that's where all the drama kind of
unfolds and I think it's really cool
because we're not trying to recreate
anything it's super meta right it's a
little bit like a docu style series kind
of like the office vibe but we actually
get to see interviews of you guys I
think they're really cool thing about
the Doc you style format is that like
all of our characters get to sort of
unfold in this really realistic way and
we get to always be very true to what a
2019 high school environment looks like
it's kind of their internal thoughts as
to what's going on because nobody else
can see that or hear that so it's kind
of a really great way for the audience
to kind of get to see where our
characters are at throughout the season
it was my idea to take a pause I didn't
want to take a pause I can't believe it
she's dating each age as well
this is a nightmare I know you guys have
been doing interviews I heard since like
7 o'clock this morning 8 o'clock this
morning what is the question that you
were just sick of being asked at this
point oh what's the question that you
keep getting asked have I already asked
it what's the question did you grow up
watching I've seen the original movie 37
times and the first 15 minutes of those
sequels who's the baby of the group so
you're 15 yes okay so you were born in
2004 yeah
yeah so I don't I don't know of you
necessarily were watching it when it
first came out no you would think I
wasn't the target demographic but I had
all of the merch I had all the dolls I I
listen to all the music and of course we
watch the movies multiple times so me
and my sister were really big fans and I
think somehow I think it had everything
for everyone yeah something that I've
been saying today is I'm 16 so I was
something that's so special about the
original high school musical films was
that it is not only like it wasn't only
big like the year that it came out it
was big then it was big like 10 years
ago and it's big now and it will
continue to be big
that's just how iconic it is so you
don't really need to be part of a
feeling to be a certain age to enjoy the
films well and thanks to you guys too I
mean the fact that you guys are
breathing new life into it and I've had
the chance to watch an episode and you
guys are you guys are amazing you're all
so talented and you also genuinely
represent the spirit of what it is and
yet you also get a chance to have some
like little you know Starkey hints at it
at the same time and it's like you you
can tell that it's real you know and
then I feel the real genuine love so
this just just a little bit of love to
you guys from me
those who did watch the movies growing
up was there a character that you guys
related to more than another don't feel
pressure because I'm sitting here there
is no pressure but you know are there
jocks or they're theater nerds are there
I mean was there click that you guys
felt like you related to or a character
that you guys related to probably call
her I just saw her and I saw myself and
I was just like I can be like that I
love that like I wouldn't be good at
science and I just related to her so
much I mean I was obsessed with High
School Musical I knew all the songs
still know all the choreography so yeah
it's just I'm so grateful to be a part
of this and with so many talented people
I mean have y'all what about your your
audition process I know for us when they
brought us in we had to go in and do our
main audition then we had to go back in
and do a callback and then we had to go
back in and read for Kenny Ortega and
then we had to go back in and dance then
we had to go back and sing they brought
me back in to play basketball which was
that day it worked out somehow and we
got onto set it was like oh we're in
trouble you guys have that same process
that you had just like a numerous hoops
to jump through or or what cuz you guys
do everything it was kind of I think we
all had to sing in our dishes yeah I was
the first person cast which was crazy I
was reading with a bunch of different
people and every single person that came
in that I read with who's sitting here I
was like that's the one in my head like
I really I wanted him to be and it was
crazy that it worked out that way
specifically with Olivia she came in you
know they told me I wouldn't be singing
that day I was just reading with a bunch
of different nannies and then they come
out and they go hey can you sing I'm
like okay sure
and like you want you to do acapella I
was like I think somebody has a guitar
so I ran out to the waiting room to one
of the other Nene's
I borrow your guitar real quick she
gives you the guitar we spend two
minutes in like one of the offices in
the Disney Channel building put together
a rendition of town Tamiya by Bruno Mars
you know the harmonies we go inside do
it for all of Disney and from then on it
just clicked so yeah and then they
assumed I could dance which was wrong I
think first recording session they're
like so your first dance rehearsals on
Monday and I was like what are you
talking about so yeah that was a
struggle but we made it so do we have
competition for who is more the struggle
with the dancing I want to hear from
everybody else who out of out of the two
of them who definitely have four left
feet had us do just dance rehearsals
with a choreographer like not for the
show just like less it had us do like we
ever so there was just random songs that
we'd learn every day go ahead and I
believe they were gauging your abilities
I know I know they brought me in for a
moving groove basically I guess just to
see if I can move now having gone
through your move and groove classes how
do you feel on your you're gonna come
see your level of dancing you still feel
like it's all the confidence game it's
all accompanied then and I feel so much
better about it now yeah you're right as
long as you feeling confident out there
you know if you can just go and do
whatever just have that stanky confident
face body
yeah excuse me is there some where
you're supposed to be Broadway in the
spirit of high school I want to play a
little game with you guys figure out
what your high school superlative would
be who would most likely be the one to
get the dance party started music walks
into like he brings a speaker every
place he walks into he enters with music
I've actually bought a portable speaker
just for filming yeah when we started
filming cuz I like to start every day
when
walk into the hair makeup trailer with
some Jackson 5 tune or whatever you know
and everybody groovin and use the
tension a little bit and everyone has a
good time or hand roll just like most
likely to be caught at crafty I think a
lot of times Frankie would turn to me
and be like hey you wanna go get a snack
of course I would never say no so yeah
like I have a little breaks I should go
get something to eat
Ford what do I do go smorgasbord of crap
for me who is most likely to be late to
set was one time when none of my alarms
in office so I've never got ready faster
in my entire life
unfortunately I made it work but yeah so
I guess if you had to pick somebody I'd
be most likely to be caught checking
their social media well they come in on
that photo okay yes I think the three of
us in this back right corner are the
social fun story live and I set limits
on each other's instagrams yeah parental
controls to hold you there accountable
right so anyway do you guys get alerts
on each other or some downwards but just
like if she wants to go on her Instagram
for more than 30 minutes a day I'd have
to get a password and vice-versa
here's the problem is that sometimes you
have to go more than thirty for work and
we both forgot the passwords for each
other's and because it's a parental lock
there is no backdoor literally cannot go
in our instagrams for more than 30
minutes a day even if we want to those
of you out there
are going why aren't they were sorry
it's not therefore they lock themselves
at home
so who's most likely to play a prank on
set responsible I'm not scary yeah I
like to scare Peter is the best one to
scare because you just like whisper
behind you freaked out so I always had
fun scaring that's good cuz like I
always think it's like a ghost or
something cuz like you can't fight you
can fight a person can't buy to go there
are you like are you gonna smack
somebody up Ali do you remember this he
convinced Dara that there was a ghost
and we convinced her that there was a
haunting in the bowling alley and I've
like take pictures me oh my god do you
see that like she's like oh my gosh it's
a go wait okay
were you guys staying either at the for
the booth at one point alright so I have
a story okay so so I at the time I was a
minor when we shot the movie so I had my
mom with me and at one point we had we
had separate rooms but they met they had
a door in between okay and so we had we
shared a bathroom one morning we both
woke up to all of the stuff on the
counter all thrown away the toothpaste
was squeezed out of the tube on to the
counter and then their wrist and this
that was that was one night but we would
be listening to the radio and it was one
of those old like dial ones that you
turn and it would change the station
[Laughter]
day one best onset bromance I do have a
soft spot for Frankie there's something
about him I just guess okay Matt loves
when he's doing this thing on camera
thanks guys thanks who is the one that
is most likely to geek out over an OG
HSN Cosmo wait you're all pointing to
each other so I had a full-sized
cardboard cutout a Zac Efron I don't
know if you know him or not
who have you guys met out of the
original og cast so far besides you guys
had any questions for an OG cast member
what would that be wow that's would be
for me it doesn't have to pay for me on
how does it feel knowing that like this
legacy is gonna live on literally
forever and you will always be known
like from this movie and from this frame
and like it's literally gonna live
forever so you know what you predict
that future for us because that is
awesome it is still surreal the fact
that I'm sitting here in front of you
guys that I'm talking to you guys and
you have this High School Musical the
musical the series behind you
when you were two years old when we were
sitting here and doing this exact same
thing all the press junk and said then
we did three movies together and then
the
to international tours together it's
been nuts for us because obviously when
we were in it we were teenagers and it
was amazing but then as we continue to
get older and new generations continue
to watch it and people will all of a
sudden telling me you're my childhood
it's weird and it's real and it's
amazing and I honestly I was so nervous
when I found out about this new series
and just getting to meet you guys and
watch you guys it has been so awesome
and I could not be prouder to be a part
of this and to be able to just know that
it's you guys that are carrying on the
legacy so it feels amazing and
especially knowing that it's in the best
hands so congratulations to you guys
Gretchen's on the second season and you
guys keep on doing your thing
[Music]